marci Martha may see Martha Martha Marcy
May Marlene stars Elizabeth Olsen and
it's the tale of a girl who gets
involved with some pretty bad people
becomes very traumatized by it and then
reconnects with a relative and tries to
collect her life and put it back
together after going through some pretty
harrowing and interesting experiences
through being forced to do various
things through a group of people that
told her it was right and acted like it
was normal the film is told in a
nonlinear way where we open with her
fleeing from this group of people and
then we go to where she goes then we
receive flashbacks of what she went
through and we kind of pieced together
the experiences that she had that caused
her to be very traumatized and really
someone who doesn't really know how to
live anymore because of what she went
through she's here now she seems okay
was she saying she had some boyfriend
they were in the catskills is this woful
you look like a Marcy May the film's got
a lot of praise particularly for
Elizabeth Olsen's performance which is
very good in the movie she is the sister
of the Olsen twins who looks very much
like them but it's not a twin she's very
good in the film in her performances
room I can see her doing more in the
future I'd like to see her do more in
the future in fact also Jonathan Hawkes
is in this film and you know him from
movies like identity and Winter's Bone
and he's good here too as well
this one has drawn a lot of praise from
the art community and a lot of people
have said that it's a really brilliant
film that explores what a person goes
through when they're put through
traumatizing experiences and it really
makes you feel that I didn't feel that
at all
from what yesterday you mean from where
I picked you up about three hours why I
know a lot of people who are
appreciative of art cinema are going to
be upset with me for not really
appreciating this film the same way as
they did but I'm gonna explain why I
felt this way now the film is very slow
pace and as I've said many times I don't
have a problem with that my favorite
film of the year so far is Drive which a
lot of people thought was really slow
but with this film I had trouble feeling
any sympathy or any connection with
Elizabeth Olsen's character it got to
the point where it was really starting
to bug me really all the things that she
was doing I know the film tried to
explain why she was such a traumatized
and and messed up person but she's old
enough to know that certain things
should not be done certain ways and in
this film I don't care what you went
through in the past there are certain
things that a person just knows is wrong
damn and then feeling we can't tell if
some things in memory or if it's
something we dream see with Drive the
film was slow paced in a way but I was
able to feel sympathy for the lead
character I was able to understand where
Ryan Gosling's head was I related to him
and I understood his character
motivations with this film I did not
understand Elizabeth Olsen's character I
didn't relate to her and I didn't
sympathize with her I didn't understand
where her character was at all I didn't
feel her as a character I didn't
understand her character
I'm not saying Elizabeth Olsen's
performance is bad I'm saying from a
storytelling perspective that really
bugged me you're a teacher and a leader
or I see no proven cheaty
there living animals so shoot max then
but however my main issue with this film
is the ending now a lot of people have
complained about the ending so it's very
anticlimactic and it is it's one of
those endings where you just have to
read whatever you want into it it's not
closure in any respect at all when the
movie ends it just ends goes black and
there's one of other two things you're
thinking one your other thinking that
was amazing and powerful and that just
changed my life or you're thinking wow I
don't believe it I was unfortunately the
latter I Know Who I am I am a teacher
and
just never let me be that thing she
should stay with us anything we can't
ignore the fact that behavior is insane
I'm not gonna spoil it but a lot of
people will look at the ending like the
one in this film and read all types of
things into it that perhaps the
filmmakers weren't even trying to convey
but it's just what they want to think or
what they they think happens or what
could happen and you know there are
movies like that that are really cool
like Inception but with this film it
seemed like sloppy story thing to me it
seemed like the filmmakers weren't sure
how to wrap up this story and we're
trying to do so in a way that was
hard-hitting or like a POW to the
audience you know some might really like
that
I however appreciate closure when I
watch them just delete we listen to
these I can't help but say that this
film really got under my skin in the
wrong kind of ways it bored me and I
just wasn't into it and if you're a fan
of art films like this you might be
thinking well you may have liked it more
if you simply just understood it I've
seen over a hundred new releases this
year I see a lot of movies it should be
very easy for for someone who's a film
buff like we need to be able to see a
movie and get it the first time and I
got this film and I understood exactly
what they're trying to say it's just not
my type of movie unfortunately so i'm
unfortunately gonna have to get Martha
Marcy May Marlene sc+ I can completely
understand why anyone would like this
film but it is not my type of movie my
favorite
no about you that's all
if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes